hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast on
Monday April 13th what's going on how
you did it I want to congratulate you
did you you made it past peak week of
covet 19 the most people were gonna get
it and whatever was gonna happen was
gonna happen and you got joy huh how
about that
you wore your mask you kept on your
gloves
you took your vitamin C hey hey hey hey
hey don't breathe on me six feet
[ __ ] right everybody thought you
were the [ __ ] and now look at you
you're on the other side of it huh
they're regular season is over and
you've gone into the playoff rounds look
at that you had a great [ __ ] combine
you're a blue-chip pick now well how
many people could say that yep reality
mathematically speaking over ninety-nine
percent of the world's population can
say that all right but still a lot of
people got that [ __ ] and you didn't you
didn't and I'll tell you if world
history and the causes of war that I
have learned through what we [ __ ]
either come in and go out goddamn thing
BIGBANG BIGBANG boo-boom boo-boom on my
[ __ ] house ding ding ding ding any
time anybody [ __ ] walks in and out
anyway if anything has told me what that
means okay
that you are asymptomatic after peak
week what I've learned through my
reading of history that means only one
thing and one thing only God loves you
better okay God God don't get me wrong
God loves everybody okay but certain
people he loves more okay and depend oh
my god in depending on what book you got
you guys here and that Bing Bing Bing
Bing every [ __ ] five seconds I don't
understand it do not understand it being
like a criminal is gonna stop oh they
think they [ __ ] Bing Bing Bing Bing me
if that's just coming upstairs to me
then all he's got to do is snuff me out
right yeah that's what I've learned
throughout history there are they're
depending on what book you read alright
if you read the Koran God loves Muslims
the most if you read the the Bible he
loves the Christians if you read what a
Jewish people read the Torah or is that
a kind of sushi the [ __ ] is it Bible me
they're the big know they have the Bible
they just they just stop they stopped at
the first one right they stopped at the
Old Testament and then the Gentiles kept
going and went on and made [ __ ]
Godfather three we should have stopped
at the classic we got greedy we kept
going
we kept [ __ ] going yeah just know
that I know it's a rough time I know
it's a strange time I know you're trying
to figure out what this new world means
but if you're still asymptomatic just
know that the invisible guy that only
talks to you through your thingy thing
in the middle of your chest there he
loves you more than he loved other
people avid
I learned that by going to church almost
every week Jesus loves us best even
though he made everybody well Jesus
didn't make everybody Jesus is like the
Donald Trump of the God family you know
what I mean God comes down he [ __ ] he
he ki builds the Empire the universe all
that is said the [ __ ] the black and
the white the up and the down the odds
and the even numbers the Alpha and he
may whatever the [ __ ] that [ __ ]
mumbo-jumbo [ __ ] is and then he comes in
right LP it with the better head of hair
than Donald Trump right but still he was
definitely doing something wild with
this hair you know trying to look like
the [ __ ] lead singer of the Black
Crowes you know Jesus Robinson and then
he came along and what did he do he
starts [ __ ] showing off walking on
water Hey look at this little basket of
bread I got enough for everybody you got
a little bread behind here all right
walking around no shirt on like JFK jr.
just doing anything he can to [ __ ]
add to his legacy and what happened what
happened he ran his Yap too much
he drew too much attention to himself
and just like in any respectable
respectable mob family he got himself
whacked that's what happened Jesus
became more trouble than he was worth
okay if you kept his [ __ ] shirt on
you know did a little [ __ ] miracle
here or there without anybody seeing it
you know stop calling attention to
himself but that wasn't his thing you
know he saw what his dad did in six days
you know six days guy put his feet up on
Sunday after Kevin created the whole
[ __ ] universe all right now you Jesus
okay you know you already have some sort
of weird family dynamic you know Joseph
given you the sight I having to sit
there and be alright that
wife got the god dick you know and he
somehow has to follow that it didn't
mean anything
no wait no wait he didn't bang her he I
don't know what he just looked at he
just looked at our wall right and then
she was pregnant
it's so [ __ ] hard to keep track of
those goddamn stories because there's
not like a [ __ ] grounded point that
you can start at well I guess you can
there was this couple Jesus and Mary
from that band that Jesus and Mary Chain
were they the ones that saying I got
everything to do with you whoo-hoo I'm
alive let me see Jesus and Mary Chain
what was their song what was their song
don't know what color you RADS a baby
well the other ones are saying that all
right what do we got here Jesus and Mary
Chain oh my god Oh the masked meteor a
new instructor whose [ __ ] master
classes go [ __ ] yourself don't you be
out master doing whatever the [ __ ] it is
you good at where is it come on let's
hear a little volume here
Asus these guys look a little depressed
from eight Mabini in a music video
oh it's just a guy from the cure wait a
minute there's all these depressing
people just like honey um I love when
chicks love bands like that with those
sad brooding guys you know why do they
like that because they feel less
threatened I don't wanna listen to that
guy screaming it makes me feel
uncomfortable I get that but then in the
back he had Yoshi thinking when you see
that guy with that [ __ ] tumbleweed
haircut you know looking down at the
ground like oh I don't really want to do
is the record labels making me make the
video are they thinking in their head
this is the kind of rock star I could be
with because I think I could control him
you know he's not getting any puss puss
with that [ __ ] look on his face right
staring at the ground
drawn [ __ ] half-moons with one foot
in the dirt [ __ ] heads in his pockets
they reversed Jim Morrison [ __ ] do you
think you're doing
you got the vibe as somebody who worked
at Kinkos back in the day oh my god
remember the kinko [ __ ] they were the
worst or were we the worst I'd come in I
well you place it down face down and you
hit start or print all right old
freckles all freckles is down 11 pounds
he's sticking with his diet and I'm here
to tell you that over 50 you can get
your abs back if you're willing to put
in the [ __ ] and just not eat anything
that's remotely [ __ ] I don't you get
used to it you get used to it but um
I've decided yeah I'm gonna get my abs
back and I'm gonna be able to play good
times bad times I've done neither yet
but I've come closer
all right I did [ __ ] up yesterday
because we had a little Easter dinner
and it was a little bit of chocolate
cake there Billy is great hey Tom
chocolate cake one of my favorite bits
of all time yeah so I did a little bad
yesterday but you know I'm gonna be good
for the rest of the fall can week and
then I've just been doing my [ __ ]
little a b ab workout every day and then
at night when everybody's to bed right I
go out to the garage and I just work on
the good times bad times thing and my
wonderful instructor Davie Lich helped
me out once again I said why don't
[ __ ] get it I can sit here and play
this lick at 80 85 bpms and then I try
to play it with the song and I crap out
at 70 or 75 what's going on and he just
said let me ask you this how are you
practicing it are you just sitting there
doing it for how long I said like 5-10
minutes he goes yeah you're burning your
foot out it's just like oh yeah I didn't
notice that so now I changed my approach
so I do it for a few minutes leave it
alone play a couple songs come back to
it and it's made a world of difference
of difference made a world of difference
as I say Mary made a world of difference
yeah some reason I thought it was
differences so I just keep doing that
now have I [ __ ] told you guys about
this kid that I'm following on Instagram
have I where the [ __ ] is my phone I know
my phone I got it I got to give a
shout-out to this kid this [ __ ] kid
is amazing I don't know how old he is
but he looks like he's like [ __ ] 17
18 years old he's playing all these old
school like note 4 [ __ ] note this kid
is playing all these old school like
Buddy Rich Max Roach Roy Haynes haven't
seen a mess with Tony Williams yet you
got to see this kid
Papa Joe Jones stuff alright
he it's Grayson gr e YN underscore
I don't know spanic Reutimann and ek ru
t ma n just go on his site I just
watched his note-for-note Buddy Rich
just [ __ ] killing this [ __ ] I know I
think I brought this up before but
absolutely incredible it's really cool
to see somebody that young that is into
that [ __ ] because my dad used to listen
to all that stuff so I grew up on that
and a lot of that type of stuff plus the
crazy [ __ ] that I was listening to her
at least the [ __ ] that he thought was
crazy I'm I'm used to call all of our
music jungle culture because right
around that time what was that ban do
you really wanna hurt me didn't they
have jungle in the knee do you really
[ __ ] lose it I literally just had the
name but then I said wait culture club
culture club and then he called it
jungle culture because they had some
[ __ ] song that had jungle in it he
goes what he wasn't that jungle culture
and it didn't make a difference what
anything was that was just it was all
jungle culture so anyways yeah check him
out and then I followed this other one
[Music]
let's see if this is what we've gotten
to considering there's just nothing
going on in the world let's just let's
look at some of the [ __ ] that I thought
that I follow on Instagram I'm not gonna
be able to find any of it now I follow
obviously all things comedy I follow
back in the day cars underscore between
all of those that's really [ __ ] cool
because you will see some classic cars
that are worth a fortune and somebody's
driving it in the snow because it's like
old school pictures like from back in
the day take
I'm just not like the all the the you
know me command you know everything is
[ __ ] mint on it Nate Smith drums
I am Derek Bennett bass player then
there's one I follow it's like solo
Dallas is a great one what's the one
hand there's one dr. Steve Gadd of
course I follow one that says trucks
your dad would drive I think is what it
is if that seventies perspective that's
just a dumb [ __ ] that I [ __ ] I don't
know there's something about lions too
of course now nobody none of them have
posted now I watch a bunch of [ __ ] about
lions and for whatever [ __ ] reason I
do watch a bunch of [ __ ] lately animals
killing each other and I also watch a
bunch of [ __ ] about helicopters my dream
helicopter which used to be the [ __ ]
used to be the [ __ ] Huey 500 the one
from [ __ ] magnum p.i and now I can't
I like the a-star 350 that's the one if
I could have any one I think that that's
the one that I would have only because
they hey the back seat is uncomfortable
and what is it I think it's an MD 500
now wait did I mention I cleaned out my
garage it is [ __ ] immaculate my
garage is so [ __ ] clean with the
epoxy floor that I take my shoes off my
sneakers my gym shoes I take them off
when I go [ __ ] in there everything
laid out where it needs to be and I'm
loving it and guess what happens the
second I get it cleaned out my wife you
know cuz she's [ __ ] going nuts she's
like oh I was thinking ever the closet
redone
so my god yeah but ba-ba-ba-ba-ba and
she goes you know make some more space
to be Babu Babu and there's just one
closet where we have all our luggages in
there so she was saying or her plans for
that closet and I go so where would the
where would all those big pieces of
luggage go and she goes oh out in the
garage and I go I [ __ ] knew it I
finally got everything off the [ __ ]
floor I hate a [ __ ] you know Oprah
Winfrey loves bread I hate clutter the
way she loves bread
I [ __ ] hate I hate clutter and I
[ __ ] hate the garage is one of the
coolest [ __ ] places in the house if
it's neat and I [ __ ] there's nothing
cooler than when you go over a man's
house a [ __ ] man's man and you go out
there he's got all his tools [ __ ]
where they're supposed to be the floor
is [ __ ] gleaming there's an old
[ __ ] classic car or truck and the
[ __ ] things he's got a set of drums
it my [ __ ] garage is the [ __ ] little
area to work out to keep the dad bought
under [ __ ] control okay you go over a
man's house he [ __ ] says hello
we shakes your head he gives you some
roast beef you're trying to size him up
I'll tell you you have no idea who the
[ __ ] is sitting across from until you go
out and you look at his goddamn garage
alright if you go out in his garage and
it is a [ __ ] mess you don't want to
get in business with that guy if you go
out there and there's a bunch of lady
[ __ ] out there [ __ ] strollers and old
dresses and [ __ ] this guy has his junk
tucked between his legs and he's not
going to be able to take the ball over
the goal line okay and at that point you
take his dead fish [ __ ] hand you
shake it you thank him for the [ __ ]
roast beef or whatever the [ __ ] saying
when she made you and you walk out and
you don't even look back because you
know
see him standing on the top of his front
steps right his bottom lip quivering as
he thinks about the man he could have
been knowing why that you're leaving you
don't want to see that you get in your
car right you put on a little night
Ranger and you [ __ ] drive away sorry
um so anyway she's trying to tell me
that no the closet people are going on
my closet people it's a [ __ ] epidemic
pandemic whatever the [ __ ] it is
hey [ __ ] come on oh sure I'm saying
after its dad iris oh they're gonna come
over here and they're gonna do some [ __ ]
my gay rush it's usually called the
garage but this is called a garage cuz I
go into it what are you a little light
in the loafers there freckles
I got a so we're just gonna put a little
some cabinets all right in the back
right so my wife goes you know what
first they were gonna be white and I'm
like I don't want white it's gonna look
boring you know just a row of white
cabinets and then also a garage is an
inherently dirty place no matter how
much you clean it up right the [ __ ]
landscapers come over they got the
[ __ ] leaf that always gets underneath
the the the goddamn thing they're right
all my little buddy the lizard I think
he got eaten by his snake I haven't seen
him in a while
made me really sad but now there's some
more lizards like the geckos they they
[ __ ] hang out it was kind of open the
dude was gonna be alright because he was
uh you know he had a safe haven in my
garage and but you know when you're a
lizard when you're a gecko you're
basically you know you're an appetizer
you just you're the you know you're like
the slider of the lizard family so I
haven't seen any of my buddies lately
they all had names and now they're gone
so now
is one little one that my daughter loves
but is also scared of she likes it cuz
it's a baby one when it tries to run
away from us and it's on the epoxy floor
and it can't get a grip is doing like a
million miles an hour with its legs but
it's only going like half a mile an hour
and it kind of freaks her out but anyway
so I was like I don't like she goes how
about black naked alright that could be
cool and then I was like I kind of have
like a baby blue wall in my garage I was
thinking about what about a little
darker blue but a matte blue with black
handles and she's like and in hinges and
she's just like no no and in my head I'm
like we made a deal when we got into
this house the house was yours the
garage was mine why are you making
decisions on the color of the carpets
you know and she just looked at me and
left so evidently I'm getting the matte
black which is a little hacky I think at
this point but I think it's gonna look
good up against the blue maybe I don't
know but anyway and then my my little
podcast area I'm finally I'm getting a
bookshelf that's of quality now unlike
the last one and I'm getting all my [ __ ]
and everything's gonna be [ __ ] ready
to go here so I'm gonna come out of this
quarantine alright
with over fifty ABS which means you
still want my shirt on you don't want to
see him you just want to be like oh you
know for an old guy he looks alright
with all of those clothes on key part of
that sentence is all of those clothes on
anyway so I got to tell you guys this as
much as I am enjoying being home and
getting all of this [ __ ] done you know
spending time with my family losing
weight getting eight hours sleep having
some time off
I really miss going out there and making
you guys laugh and I am thankful that I
get to do this but I can't hear you
laughing in fact someone I went to high
school with sent me a text message and
he goes hey man I was listening to your
podcast she made me laugh bah bah bah
bah whatever the hell I said and it
actually the text message really made me
feel good you know cuz I [ __ ] I never
thought that wedding minute I've did
stand-up for so [ __ ] long 28 goddamn
years never took a break this this is
the longest I've gone without doing
stand-up since I started and easily and
I remember saying to my wife numerous
times going you know cuz I kept saying I
was gonna retire from this [ __ ] when I'm
around 70 she goes you're never gonna
retire you're gonna die on stage I go
yeah yeah I go you know you don't get it
you don't [ __ ] get it right and I
think she's after taking a month off
here I think she's right
it's too much goddamn fun it's too much
fun and I just keep thinking a dumb [ __ ]
that I want to say or start talking
about cuz that's how the process works
with the [ __ ] that I do and I go
that's kind of a [ __ ] up thing to
think I'm gonna start talking about that
tonight on stage and see where it goes
huh do you think any I wonder what you
know it's gonna be weird coming out of
all of this I want I'm wondering if the
white chicks lost all their momentum you
know during this whole woke time that
was it's actually supposed to be
about people of color until white women
took the whole [ __ ] thing over and
that's all anybody decided to listen to
was them I'm just wondering if they have
lost any of their momentum and I have to
tell you from the bottom of my heart if
they have I think it's really funny out
of all the complaining that I heard all
of it made sense there was all valid
points but the ones that made the least
amount of sense but for some reason were
the loudest was all these white broads
[ __ ] complaining white broads married
to white men living their white lives I
couldn't believe the degree of
difficulty they couldn't believe their
their lack of perspective you know like
alright so you got it tough well look at
your place in society if you have a
tough imagine what it would be like to
be somebody who didn't look like you and
all they could focus on was white males
that's what this [ __ ] was about as much
as they acted like they gave a [ __ ]
about other people of color they didn't
all they gave a [ __ ] about was what
white what they perceived that white
males have so I have a question for you
white ladies do you ever think that
white males have so much in life as a
reward for having to deal with living
with white oh man you don't know oh
lordy you know what I watched the other
day I was watching I was watching some
classic baseball and I was watching Game
four of the 1977 World Series the New
York Yankees first day Los Angeles
Dodgers and Chavez Ravine back in early
October 1977 I remember watching that
series it's one of the first was first
world
series that I watched it was [ __ ]
hilarious it came on like during the day
I'd come home after school the goddamn
game was oh wait no it started in like
four or five three or four in the
afternoon so I'm still seven o'clock at
night so we were watching the thing and
just watching and I was once again
trying to memorize all the teams and
they came right back to me
Thurman months in the late great Thurman
Munson at catcher and then he had I
always forget it's Greg or Craig Nettles
I just remembered that he caught he has
his check swing pop fly out for that one
game playoff in 78 Bucky Dent at
shortstop Willie Randolph at second
Chris Chambliss at first and then their
outfield was [ __ ] Lou Piniella Mickey
rivers and the one and only Reggie
Jackson and then the [ __ ] Dodgers had
Steve yaga yaga Meister Steve Yeager who
just was like he was the 70s
he had the 70s glasses he had the
[ __ ] permed out [ __ ] curly-q
[ __ ] hairdo he just was the coolest
looking dude right and then yeah and Ron
Cey the penguin at third I think he was
there he might have got there in 78 but
I didn't see him I watched a couple
innings I don't remember him getting up
to bat and no wait I think he did I
think he flew out Lou Piniella robbed
him of a home run Davey Lopes at Short
know at second Russell was it Bill
Russell like the Celtics was it short
Steve Garvey movie star looking dude
at first base then it was dusty out
left-field Reggie Smith and then likely
lacy or something Tommy Lasorda was the
manager of the [ __ ] Dodgers and Billy
Martin was the manager for the Yankees
they just date-date they don't make them
like that anymore and interestingly
enough pitching for the Dodgers not in
this game on their staff was Tommy John
which everybody knows his name from
Tommy John surgery because he was the
first guy
they took the ligament from your [ __ ]
leg and stuck it in your elbow and it
actually worked he was the first guy so
it's called Tommy John surgery so here's
a deal Heep I know I've brought this up
before in the podcast but you know
whatever there's nothing going on in the
world I'm talking about a [ __ ] World
Series game from 43 years ago all right
Tommy John played on the Dodgers in 77
and 78 they went to the World Series and
they lost to the New York Yankees in
1981 Tommy John is on the New York
Yankees and they played the Los Angeles
Dodgers in the World Series and the
Yankees lose to the Dodgers I don't know
if anybody has matched that Marian Hossa
came close where one year he played for
the Penguins and lost to the Red Wings
in the finals the next year he was on
the Red Wings and then lost to the
Penguins and then the next year he was
on the [ __ ] Blackhawks and all I'm
thinking is if they [ __ ] lose this
one this is going to be the first guy in
three consecutive years has to be that
lost in the Stanley Cup Finals on three
different [ __ ] teams but fortunately
the Blackhawks won and he was spared
that embarrassing stat so I was watching
that and I'm hoping you know what my
favorite my favorite [ __ ] baseball
team of all time
other than the 2004 Boston Red Sox would
have to be the 1979 Pittsburgh Pirates
the we are they were my favorite
baseball team of all time Willie
Stargell [ __ ] Dave Parker and OTT Kent
to Kobe John Candelaria with a Foley at
second base or something like that I
can't remember Omar Moreno and then they
went up against [ __ ] and Earl Weaver
with Eddie Murray Eddie I'm not smiling
Murray
Eddie 500-something legit [ __ ] home
runs no steroids no coffee beans go [ __ ]
yourself his scowl sent that ball over
the [ __ ] goddamn fence they had a
Frank Tanana Rick Dempsey remember all
of those [ __ ] guys also I've been
cleaning up also all on my [ __ ] and and
I found all on my football car it's just
going back through those things I've
been watching the highlights from like
1970s football and I found this great
quarterback for the [ __ ] Denver
Broncos that was somehow between right
before Craig Mort and Craig Morton
really interesting career where he took
over for Don Meredith with the Cowboys
he was the the Cowboys starting
quarterback for two years before Roger
Staubach came in then he got traded to
the Giants and then after the Giants he
went to the Denver Broncos and with the
Broncos he ended up facing his old team
the Dallas Cowboys in Super Bowl 12 and
lost like twenty seven to ten all right
Charlie Denver Broncos QB what was this
guy's name Charlie Johnson CH AR le Y
Johnson and this is great there's this
great clip of him talking about his
first start as a QB this is back when
they were really forgiving of starting
quarterbacks just going you know they
never win and that they you know and
Charlie Johnson talks about his first
game saying like man I thought I had the
offense down I thought I could read
defenses and all that we played the
Green Bay Packers and he goes I did
throw two touchdown passes but
unfortunately they would both to Green
Bay defensive backs has like a Southern
drawl just like the old school you know
gunslinger you know when I was a kid
they had this week in baseball bump well
done that bad at the bat but the pop up
a bad is fine they showed all the
highlights from around the league's
before they had [ __ ] ESPN
this is the only way you really could
watch all these cool highlights and I
guess they had this week in football
this week in professional football with
Pat Summerall and that other guy used to
[ __ ] and drink with and literally would
be hammered like legally drunk before
games and they'd be like laughs and it
was like a joke that they were [ __ ]
drunk and nobody cared because being
drunk was funny back then foster Brooks
said oh [ __ ] act about being an
alcoholic was just a funny [ __ ] thing
yeah back then alcoholism was [ __ ]
hilarious unless you would the poor
woman married to it or the guy married
to it then it was really sad but they
had this show on so they have like
highlights the 74 season 75 he watched
all the weeks the old uniforms the old
stadiums and I just been watching their
like 42 43 minutes long they're [ __ ]
tremendous cannot recommend them enough
and what else have I been watching
[ __ ] hate when I do that I was trying
to check to see how much time I had done
to see if I needed to read the
advertisement hit stop and I gotta
[ __ ] edit the goddamn thing together
well God knows I have the time anyway my
mother-in-law called me up she was like
bill you got to watch this show so I
said alright put it on it was called
it's called flipping Boston they did
like two seasons since these two guys
who basically in the Lynn area
Marblehead Lowell they like flip houses
let's see how this poem goes Lynn Lynn
the city of cinn you never go out the
way you went in and there's actually
there's a second verse right Lynn Lynn
the city the city of sin you never come
out the way you went in why is my
stomach growling so much it's because
I'm not eating
you asked for water but they give you
gin the girls say no yet always give in
if you're not bad they won't let you in
it's the damndest city I ever lived in
Lin Lin the city of cinn you never come
out the way you went in now I'm sure
it's all [ __ ] yuppies and [ __ ] but
that's a great ass for water but they
give you gin the girls say no yet they
always give in if you're not bad they
won't let you in it's the damnedest city
I've ever been in I mean I've ever lived
it come on man and I'm like how the
person who live in there is judging the
people there you know it's like well
wait am i how the [ __ ] did you end up
there you must be a piece of [ __ ] - stop
trying to separate yourself
so anyways he's too [ __ ] guys and one
of the guys has the craziest accent ever
he has an English accent and a Boston
accent combined which I'm not even gonna
try to attempt to do but what I love
about him is he's always talking about
his temper I'll tell you right now I'm
at about a seven and you don't want to
see me at an eight I'll tell you right
now I'm about ready to do some
demolition on the south of my [ __ ]
fist every single [ __ ] house
there is a goddamn problem but their
best one is when they have this neighbor
who I think a lot of people have dealt
with when you're doing a job they just
start calling the board of whatever to
come over and then you get fined in all
of this [ __ ] they just [ __ ] jealous
that you're improving your [ __ ] house
I have a friend of mine she was doing
some work on our house and I guess it
was semi you know I guess it wasn't
legal and this fair [ __ ] neighbor
knew it and he waited until the day they
were done and then reported him and made
him tear it down and I was like wow is
that grounds for [ __ ] severely
vandalizing that guy's house at some
point you would have to do something I
don't know how I would do it but I you
you you would have to do what what could
you do
well you wouldn't get caught well I
don't think enough people have like I
would just be worried about cameras
you'd have to do something really
sophomoric dog [ __ ] in the mailbox but
like a lot of it fresh - right from the
farmers market dog [ __ ] no but if you
put it in the mailbox then it's it's
definitely done by a human dogs don't
have thumbs so they know that there's no
reason the dog mistook this for some
sort of horizontal toilet so what you'd
have to do is you just have to keep
putting this is what I would do I would
pick up dog [ __ ] in the neighborhood and
I would drop it I would drop it in the
same location every [ __ ] day well
then eventually you would film you all
right so what you need to do is you need
to get creative that just has to be
[ __ ] dog [ __ ] involved in it you know
I throw it up on his roof I would just
constantly cuz he's a piece of [ __ ] the
hood of his car and this is what you do
you just do it forever and you do it
like once every [ __ ] 30 days okay the
first day cuz he doesn't think it's
gonna happen
all right you go over there with you
covet masks on and he go over at night
and you take a nice fresh dog [ __ ] and
you put it under the driver's side door
handle or maybe all the door handles of
his [ __ ] car all right just to let
him know that he started a [ __ ] war
then you know he's not gonna like the
results of okay and he's gonna know it's
you okay and then when you see him you
give him a big smile and a how you doing
that's it right and then you just wait
and you wait and you wait and you
wait and you wait and you wait and you
wait and you wait and then you do
something else
same [ __ ] [ __ ] right nice [ __ ] dog
[ __ ] right on his front [ __ ] mat
right you know there's gonna be a
temptation to drop your pants and take a
[ __ ] human deuce right there but I
mean there's DNA you can't do that
23andme they'll [ __ ] figure out it
was your [ __ ] and then you can't you're
gonna make the national news you don't
want that all right
although there was that one guy who took
a [ __ ] on the [ __ ] serving card and
you cannot find that story anyway he was
a person of some sort of level of wealth
man shits on car airplane cart worst
ever air rage passenger jailed for
drunken rampage wait a minute this isn't
the guy he was on his way to Dubai all
right worst ever
air rage passenger jailed for drunken
rampage yeah see this isn't I thought I
bet this is I bet this is a [ __ ] lie
to cover the rich dude because it was a
rich dude who did this in like the
[ __ ] 2000s here in America all right
they're calling Jasper's ding barrage
the worst ever air rage passenger he was
given 11 months in prison for his
drunken tantrum on a flight from Dubai
to Birmingham England the judge who
handed down the sentence spared no harsh
words for mr. baracs
on the Emirates flight the greatest
airline I've ever been on you drank
vodka mixed with wine and then proceeded
to abuse cabin staff he demanded more
alcohol and swore repeatedly even though
there were four young children behind
you who had to listen to your tirade he
told a female member of the cabin crew
that if she were on the ground you would
punch her in the face
and in particularly grotesque piece of
behavior you dipped your finger in your
glass of wine and rub them on your
private parts the air hostess felt
abused and disgusted after seeing you
touch yourself in a sexually explicit
way you shouted [ __ ] Muslims send
them back to whatever they came from and
[ __ ] [ __ ] Isis when you landed you
were abusive to police and bit a PC
Engram on the arm people need to know
that if you get drunk on an airplane set
other passengers and cause cabin crew to
have a difficult job then custodial
sentences apply you have many previous
convictions and it seems you will not
learn your lesson okay but I don't think
he deserves because of the worse okay
the honorable odds to Gerard be Finneran
in 1999 Finneran this is it the 58 year
old head of an investment banking firm
was seated in the first-class cabin of a
United Airlines flight from Buenos Aires
Buenos Aires how he said to new york
taking advantage of the free liquor
being served well isn't that the
airplane's airline's responsibility in
that section of the plane Finneran half
enter and proceeded to get very very
drunk when a concerned flight attendant
refused to give him another glass of
wine Finneran took charge of the
situation and began serving himself
drinks from the beverage cart when
informed that it was against regulations
for passengers to get their own drinks
and infuriated Finneran told the flight
attendant that he was going to bust his
ass when the threat failed to achieve
veterans desired results he resorted to
Plan B going berserk terrifying
passengers knocking over crew members
and then grabbing drinks and pouring
them over his body he topped off the
show with an educational demonstration
of primate dominance by clamoring on to
the beverage
that had been placed off-limits to him
and evacuating his bowels on it by the
way that is the coolest thing way ever
to say you [ __ ] on something evacuating
his bowels it almost sounds like some
post 9-11 thing right
using the first-class linen napkins and
his fingers to wipe his hindquarters
according to the criminal complaint
filed against him this this captain of
industry then proceeded to clean his
fingers by walking up and down the
aisles tracking feces throughout the
aircraft there wasn't a blunt object
somebody could I hit him with in the
middle of that can you imagine the
screaming I bet they was screaming
louder than if the [ __ ] engines shut
off in court Finneran pleaded guilty as
charged
I'm gonna take full responsibility for
evacuating meatballs
now rubbing me [ __ ] finger digits down
the [ __ ] aisles shake fingers thank
you Nia shake fingers down the aisles
he's America this is American Irish
maybe this is why they made him leave
Ireland Wow Wow well we gotta look up
now whatever happened to this guy
what a [ __ ] Lulu this is like you
know why I blame for this the other
passengers he just kept taking it
further and further and at some point
the second a man has his pants down I
don't care what sort of UFC [ __ ] he
knows you can you can beat that guy up
all right you just step on his balls
like a [ __ ] you know you know what a
birthday party's over there's that
balloon that just lay in there the kids
aren't looking at you just step on it
it's over that's what they should have
done it was [ __ ] ball back
uh today well 58 he must be this guy
must be dead he's got to be dead 58 1995
would that be 20 years later 78 in 583
he could still be around passenger
accused of defecating pleads guilty
notes 1996 banker admits guilt on plane
oh my god
I mean me you need a new plane alright
whatever happened to whatever happened
to Gerard Finneran hey Mia what are you
doing
you are you don't want to come over here
said you don't want to come over here
alright alright I got to read some
advertising here hey Mia what was that
pasta man thing wheel documentary
watching last night would that [ __ ]
guy made that unbelievable pasta was it
funky fu n ke on Hulu - they still have
a restaurant out here my god okay cool
I'll be right there no she can say hi so
so the name of the documentary is funky
fu n ki fu n ke on Hulu this guy making
pasta is incredible hey whoops
[Music]
your baby tooth grew in did you put your
other tooth under the pillow so you get
your secret wish what what's your secret
wish
[Music]
she I always read her this book that you
little dance I redid this book one
morning in May that's right so she plays
she pretends to dig clams like little
Sal that's right and the other day I was
reading blueberries for Sal and you know
the whole book by heart now the house
one yeah
what ones that and they're canning them
for what the I can't him for that house
that's right all right can you say Happy
Easter everybody all right buddy
let me do the rest of this okay all
right yeah so I was reading blueberry
blueberries for Sal
a Robin McCloskey book and one morning
in Maine make way for ducklings a time
for something or other I've gotten them
all at this point I got to get that
lentil one and now she wants to go to
Bucks Harbor at some point which is way
up in Maine and is actually mr. Condon's
where he kept store actually still
exists or no the the the the autobody
place where he fixes the guys outboard
motor if you've read the books you know
what I'm talking about you like what the
[ __ ] this guy talking about all right
all right simply safe everybody you know
with all the uncertainty in the world
feeling safe at home has never been more
important it's why I want to talk to you
about simply safe home security
their longtime friends of shows named
the Monday morning podcast and for good
reason
simply safe has made it easy to finally
get comprehensive protection for your
home oh yes so if you're trying to get
your neighbor back if they have simply
safe you're gonna get caught
there's no technician or salesperson
that needs to come and disrupt your
house you don't need to pay any
outrageous monthly fees or sign a
two-year contract just order online set
up yourself in under an hour and your
home is protected 24/7 with emergency
dispatch for break-ins fire and more all
for just fifty cents a day and we're not
the only fan to simply say it's us news
world and World Report name simply safe
best overall home security of 2020 right
now when you head to simply safe calm /
/ my listeners will get free shipping
and a 60-day risk-free trial that's
simply safe calm / / to make sure they
know that our show sent you from simply
safe and all of us here wishing you
safety and good health and I got one
other LegalZoom everybody health and
safety is on top of everyone's mind
right now no matter what happens you
want to make sure your loved ones are
protected
that's why Legal Zoom continues to
provide a reliable way for everyone to
set up the right estate plan without
leaving your home it starts with finding
the answers to your questions do you
need a last will and testament or a
living trust what about an advanced
health care directive and what's the
power when what's a power of attorney
Thanks that that's power of attorney
means somebody can sign can be you on a
legal document don't ever give that away
do not never give away power of attorney
you have to sign the [ __ ]
all right thankfully you don't have to
figure everything out on your own legal
zooms online resources make it easy to
get and if you need to speak to an
attorney they're independent attorney
network is there to guide and advise you
Legal Zoom isn't a law firm so you won't
have to worry about expensive billable
hours adding up take important steps for
your family today go to legalzoom.com to
get started on a last will living trust
and Mo
or find out how you can speak to an
attorney for advice on the right estate
plan LegalZoom where life meets legal
all right so I've been getting crazy
back into cooking even though I'm just
cooking kind of like not fun healthy
[ __ ] I have been cooking for my ladies
my lovely ladies here at the house and
so I've decided that I'm gonna learn how
to make my own bread and what not I just
you know not even cuz of this [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's going on it's just
something that looks like a lot of fun
it takes me back to being a little boy
and playing in the [ __ ] mud that's
what I like about bake baking there's
something just [ __ ] sloppy about it
yeast hey Billy sourdough tips I'm in
[ __ ] great shape I don't know why I
get all these these tits this at its
that a'right I've you know I've had
problems with the booze and I put on the
way pump I'm [ __ ] I'm tipping the
scales here the buck 69 170 all right 32
[ __ ] years out of high street for if
I didn't stay back you know making yeast
disease I can do what you do just two
ingredients no need to pay high prices
for it two for some lunatic who's
hoarding it here's the recipe
ingredients 1 in 1/4 C I'm assuming
that's a cup of unbleached all-purpose
flour or milled wheat / wheat berries 1
cup of clean warm water sterile jar with
cheesecloth or lid instructions mix the
flour in warm water and keep it room
temperature after several days the
mixture will start to bubble and will
begin to rock whenever I see that word i
remember that louis c.k bit where he was
arrested and they made him stripped down
naked and he had his hands out to the
sides and the cop goes alright I need
you to lift my testicles and he was
standing there goes
well can I use my hands or do you just
want me to be like pickles some jokes
just stay with you that one always
stayed with me keep you in the
refrigerator when not in use use as you
would any sourdough starter that's all
there is to it and then I just do the
sourdough thing yeah isn't that called
the mother
all right vaccine yo bill back in high
school four years ago you turned me on
to a healthy way of thinking about the
news and the things they intentionally
get is mad about oh good I'm glad you
bought into my way of looking at the
world I hope I'm right I was wondering
if you were skeptical about the idea the
idea of getting a Cove advancing or
possibly just we're weary of being part
of the first wave a very comprehensive
article about the company behind the
vaccine we be getting was put out this
week here's the gist of it since Billy
no news won't read it yeah I also don't
look at anything until I do the podcast
so let's see bio-port is about to go
bankrupt I think was about to go
bankrupt in 2011 because they couldn't
account for millions the government gave
them for research and development
they're about to go bankrupt but 9/11
happens and they're anti anthrax vaccine
is needed so instead of being happy they
still had a business now so instead of
being happy they still had a business
they doubled down and lobbied for
enormous amounts of stockpiled vaccines
to be sold to the government it was
later proven that they had foreknowledge
of the anthrax attacks they rebrand as
emergent and cornered the market on the
anti-drug of treating opioid overdoses
and quickly made it too expensive for
mass distribution while suing
competitors making anything as close as
effective a man on the board of this
company was in charged of
defense under Bush and push to vaccinate
troops with bio Thrax
a drug not approved by the FDA huge
shocker it wasn't safe killed 20 active
servicemen and over 4,000 became ill so
when it comes to Co vyd I'm sure they're
on the case all right I'll send you guys
this link and you guys can make up your
own mind but uh you know we've heard one
cell we've heard the prosecution's case
yeah I don't know I don't know guys I'm
just I'm [ __ ] I'm living I live a
little life all right that I mean that
sounds like the plotline of the next
Marvel [ __ ] eight movie Ock trilogy
however II say eight part series is that
a miniseries I don't [ __ ] know all
right the name bill comma I thought the
whole story was ridiculous
I work in radiation and my wife works in
the ER this has to be a voice text who
starts a [ __ ] email I thought the
whole story was ridiculous it's like I
just walked in on a conversation
I work in radiation with my wife and my
wife works in the ER since January all
medical professions called it that what
the name
I'm Chinese born in China
my wife is Korean born in Korea calling
it that doesn't make it racist just
because someone you don't like calls it
that everyone called the Wu Han virus
and the China virus interchangeably
interchangeably for months no one called
it the corona because there are lots of
corona viruses so why would you call it
just that all the energy and time wasted
on every news outlet and Twitter people
with nothing to do all day could have
gone towards deploying better
information well you're also making the
assumption that everybody who jumped on
Twitter and got up in arms and that was
actually working on some sort of vaccine
or making people safe it's just
mouth-breathers talking and I don't
necessarily think
what he was like at face value it's not
racist but his background where he sees
both sides of me a story involving
neo-nazis and a dead protester of
neo-nazis he's like well there's two
sides to each story that type of [ __ ]
among other things is why yeah you're
not gonna convince me that the guy is
not a full-on [ __ ] just overtly
[ __ ] racist dude because I don't have
a problem with conservative politics I
have a problem with sanity and somebody
being fit for the job and I felt that
when he called it the China virus it
wasn't like necessarily my first thought
was that's racist is that I looked at it
like this guy is [ __ ] himself and
he's the quarterback of the team and
he's coming back to the huddle pointing
fingers and yelling at the refs and
doing all of this [ __ ] and what we need
is Joe Montana right now to come to the
huddle and be like hey isn't that John
Candy and the [ __ ] crowd and
everybody's like wow look how [ __ ]
relaxed he is we're gonna be fine rather
than [ __ ] yourself so I know whether
people said that it was [ __ ] racist
but like you're not gonna convince me
otherwise that the guy isn't racist
I think how you are possibly in the way
you view saying this I don't think in
your heart the way you're writing this
that you are you know what I mean so I
would say that but let's let's continue
on here anyway but I cancelled a trip to
visit family in February because Trump
talked about travel ban in January and I
didn't want to get stuck there my white
friends tried to play it to me like it
sucks that the racist is keeping you
from your family now I believe that too
because I also believe that people
[ __ ] hate Trump to a point that
they're not even like rational but I
don't blame them for that I think that
if you watch CNN and you watch Fox News
every day you have an extreme hatred
for half of your fellow countrymen which
is just an absolutely reprehensible /
treasonous thing that the 24-hour news
networks both on the left and the right
have done to each other we should be I
should be able like Eileen left I should
be able to sit down with somebody on the
right and listen to their points of view
and we should be able to [ __ ] talk
and hang and be Americans and also back
in the day you didn't bring up religion
or politics because he didn't want to
[ __ ] argue with people and I have this
weird hybrid thing when I was raised
conservative sort of became level and
then kind of veered back a little bit
conservative but like I kind of stay in
the the meat of it you know what I mean
like my my conservative stuff I think
has to do with like raising kids and and
I think I'm really conservative when it
comes to that [ __ ] I'm conservative
about what you expose kids to as far as
what they watch on TV and that type of
stuff and as I think a lot of liberals
are they just don't realize those are
conservative [ __ ] viewpoints where
I've really [ __ ] draw the line
politically is like you know the extreme
religious right rapture Jesus lunatics
and then the extreme left where you know
toys shouldn't have genders and you
shouldn't be allowed to [ __ ] blah
blah blah blah blah and you know why are
we giving little boys football I don't
know cuz little boys like football you
[ __ ] idiots you know like I I don't
you know or if they know you don't force
them to play football but I'm just
saying there's no reason to [ __ ] you
know to prove whatever point you're
trying to prove that if I have a son he
has to run around with a pink football
you know to make everybody feel like hey
man like yeah man like I don't [ __ ]
get it all that it's just stupid to me
it's [ __ ] stupid because I have to be
honest with you the [ __ ] that I've heard
the extreme left say
some of the craziness of it and the way
that they've gone about aggressively
forcing their agenda down people's
[ __ ] throats is is right there with
what the [ __ ] I see on the on the
extreme right alright but like I don't
think there's anything wrong with owning
a [ __ ] gun but I think there's a
tremendous responsibility if you get a
gun you don't just buy the [ __ ] gun
and go today you will totally go through
that door a bug take an evening out like
you should know how to [ __ ] take that
thing apart put it back together
blindfolded and you should know how to
[ __ ] use it you know and you should
be constantly going to a gun range in
practicing and respecting that you have
that [ __ ] thing in the house and then
of course have it in a gun safe and all
of that which I don't get how that
[ __ ] works where somebody comes in
your house and they're running up the
stairs and you're like 36 to the right
20 to the left for my [ __ ] I guess I am
nervous you know I think this is what
you do your wife goes to the [ __ ]
safe and then you have a giant spear
like a harpoon so when that guy comes
through the door in the [ __ ] dark you
lunge and you stick him and then
hopefully she gets the gun out right but
then what I always worry about is
tinnitus my ear is is shot from playing
drums and going to concerts and not
having ear plugs back in the day and
I've also shot a five shot 38 without
earplugs and and like I don't know so
anyway so I open you guys listen to this
[ __ ] I know you guys know that I'm a
[ __ ] lefty but like I don't have
problems with people on the right as
long as you're sane and I don't have
problems with people on the left as long
as you're saying but I I do have a
problem with people who
[Music]
once you take your belief and then I
have to buy into it
and if I don't you're gonna try and
cancel me like what the left is doing
like I don't get how that's any
different than like that McCarthyism
[ __ ] back in the day trying to take
people's careers away and then they did
this thing it went beyond the person
they were upset with if you said well
hey man that guy was always cool to me
then they tried to get rid of you too
even though you didn't do anything other
than express support for the person that
they were upset with that's when it's
just like you guys have kind of become
what the [ __ ] you're allegedly against
so anyway let's discontinue my white
friends tried to play it to me like it
sucks that the racist is keeping you
from your family I don't doubt that all
right I don't care I don't thought that
that happened all right I don't care
about politics I care about facts and
numbers and records I agree with you
when the World Health Organization
reported on it in January they said the
virus might not be transmitted human to
human they knew it was but they
downplayed it by saying might my
colleagues and I knew this was [ __ ]
my wife treated someone in January and
knew it was severe I think everyone will
with common sense thought this as well
thought this as well but I can only
speak from people in my community now
it's April and when I mentioned the
travel ban to my white hero friends they
have nothing to say when I talked to my
Asian friends here in America we laugh
about how much China lies about
everything and how so many people are
dead we probably don't know about see
this is really interesting here this
[ __ ] here notice how I said we laugh
about how much China lies not that
people are dying yeah I got that he said
Bill Maher made a video about the name
this week I don't think he's very funny
and I don't watch his show but I can
agree with what he says on this and just
like the stupid conversation about the
stupid name I added to the waste of
wait and just like the stupid
conversation about the stupid name I
added to the waste of time
healthier family PS I saw Iron Maiden in
South Korea in 2011 how cool is that
I took my then 62 year old Korean
father-in-law he still refers to it as
the loud opera ah man that's [ __ ]
that's a great [ __ ] name for an Iron
Maiden album maybe not I don't know it's
a great description though you know what
that was really eye-opening a lot of
that I was guilty of some of this [ __ ]
that you said there I think in defense
of everybody we haven't had an outbreak
like this in a long long [ __ ] time a
global thing like this so I just don't
think that we were prepared for it I
think we will be in the future this is a
great dry run
and that's that but I mean the new fly
in the ointment is [ __ ] air travel
we're in a 24-hour period you can go
from New York City to Sydney Australia
and bring whatever the [ __ ] you have all
the way over there and then you sneeze
on somebody and then gets on a flight to
Singapore and there it goes so that's
good so what that person just wrote is
the kind of [ __ ] that I love to read
because it cuts through all of that
hysteria that all my CNN Fox News
friends because I have both of those you
know I have friends who on the right can
watch Donald Trump talk about banging
models make references to that in the
middle of the pandemic and see nothing
wrong with it and it's just like dude
he's the [ __ ] President of the United
States he shouldn't be talking about the
[ __ ] he's gotten okay I know JFK banged
Marilyn Monroe we know the [ __ ] they're
getting you don't talk about it
can you guys do me a favor if you have a
bang a [ __ ] model you know what's
cooler the only thing cooler than
banging a model is not telling anybody
you did it and then sitting there why
everybody's telling their [ __ ] [ __ ]
stories right I did this and I did that
and they said a [ __ ] get Ally and flood
the good day and you just sit there
nodding your head smiling hey man I
can't follow that that right there
that's the real [ __ ] deal all right
puppy dog everybody hey Bill I suggest
you get a puppy it's the perfect time
for you to get one um it'll put a smile
on your grumpy face and that joy will
spill over to your lovely daughter who's
tired of telling you to [ __ ] relax
well gee you made a lot of assumptions
there what do you mean she's tired she's
not tired of telling me to relax stop
[ __ ] super imposing your relationship
with your dad on me me and my daughter
get along [ __ ] great
it's safe to assume you live behind a
fence so you shan't worry about the
little one getting out I hope you think
this idea is a good one because if you
do my wife will give her blessings for
me to get one don't worry I'm not a cook
and I'm getting one anyways I don't I
think you ate that expression [ __ ]
that's one of those stupid internet
things that one person used it and now
everybody uses it it's kind of like now
everybody's saying tone deaf is the
latest way to say somebody isn't woke
their little tone - shut the [ __ ] up you
[ __ ] all-white world
yeah buddy I'll get a [ __ ] dog when
my life settles down
okay I'm planning on getting one right
now and my dream dog has always been a
bulldog my wife is against it we've
negotiated two French Bulldog and the
next round of negotiations was one
bulldog one French Bulldog that's it all
right
and and that's it that's gonna it's
gonna [ __ ] happen
okay it's not gonna happen right [ __ ]
now when I have a three-year-old okay
who has more goddamn energy it's like it
just keeps going up at the end of the
day like when we're putting her to bed
she's literally running around like a
crazy person yeah I'm not gonna add a
puppy to that situation when my life
settles down a little bit I will and
then also you know you also got a time
when you're gonna get a dog okay cuz you
know how long they're gonna live and you
got the kid has to be of a certain age I
don't want that the [ __ ] get a [ __ ]
Bulldog with my kids three and the thing
dies when she's 9 or 10 however those
things live like eight years like 11 I
don't need that I don't need that all
right
single mom advice on teen but I
appreciate your advice
single mom advice on teenage boys a bill
my boys and I are super huge fans I've
been a fan for many years we enjoy
watching your specials and listening to
your podcast I'm a single mom with the
son who's 14 and another that is 11 I'm
going through this teen segment of
parenting all on my own and I am curious
on what advice you may have for my boys
what are some things you are you think
are essential for a boy to grasp at this
age any wisdom you could share with them
would be awesome we would really
appreciate your thoughts thank you for
all the love oh sorry for all the
laughter you bring and please tell Nia I
love her and hearing your daughter
always makes me smile alright well you
know something this is something I was
talking to somebody the other day about
what they should teach people in school
I'm at that age oh by the way everybody
hey that's me somebody else all right I
this is the advice I would give all
right if you have a crush if they have a
crush on a girl right just walk up and
say hello tell her that you like her and
see if she'll go out with you
simple as that get over that fear all
right cuz here's the thing it's always
embarrassing the first time you do it if
they're not doing it yet it's always
[ __ ] embarrassing but once you do it
it's like doing that first open mic the
first time you bomb you survive it and
then somewhere along the line you learn
to find the humor and bombing and if you
can do that you'll never be afraid to
ask for what you want in life so right
now the chicks you want to bomb with are
the ones when you're 11 and 14 because
that's just puppy love but someday when
the girl your dream comes along you want
to have the confidence to walk up and
say hello so you get what you want in
life the most important thing ever
finding the person you're supposed to
spend your life with so you can be happy
all right
secondly you got to teach somebody how
to break up with somebody very simple
but they never teach you you just tell
the person just say hey listen we need
to talk they sit down what's up just say
listen I think you're a great person but
you know I'm just I'm not happy you know
and as much as I like you and everything
I just there isn't that thing that's
making me feel like this is a lifetime
love I have love for you but I don't
have life full lifetime love for you
something like that and there's nothing
anybody can say to that [ __ ] and then
just don't get [ __ ] rope back into it
and then they're gonna cry and they're
going to go through all of that [ __ ] and
there's no reason to be
or anything like that and just sit there
hug them be nice about it and you can
just say listen it yeah I don't want to
waste any more of your time on my time
we should both go out and find the
people that were supposed to be with
them as much as this hurts you right now
someday you're gonna find that guy that
wants to love you for the rest of your
life okay and you'll be very thankful
that I set you free to go find him
something like that
that last line might have been a little
corny but that's you got to teach him
that all right
next teach him about money all right
they're gonna be getting to the point
soon where they're gonna be going off to
college believe it or not in the next
five years for that kid who's 14 and
then they're gonna give him a [ __ ]
credit card and they're gonna get in all
of this [ __ ] bankers what they want
to do is get you [ __ ] in so much
goddamn debt before you even realize
what the [ __ ] happens you're running on
the wheel for the rest of your life and
maybe in your 60s you come out of it all
right I would show them the Goodfellas
scene after they knock off that [ __ ]
the lifts wanza heist
when Robert De Niro don't buy anything
don't buy anything if I can give you any
[ __ ] advice now that I'm cleaning out
my garage and looking at all the [ __ ]
[ __ ] I saved over the years don't buy
anything don't collect anything don't
get involved in that [ __ ] live a very
sparse sparsely furnished [ __ ] life
do not give in to [ __ ] consumerism
all right live well within your means
okay always have enough money that if
you're not liking a job you have the
time to be like [ __ ] you I'm out of here
and find something else if you suddenly
get laid off if there's a [ __ ]
pandemic you can survive all right do
not get involved in living week to
[ __ ] week less is more less is more
less is more
then as far as all the kids that you go
to school with whatever they think about
you none of it matters because in the
next five years you're gonna graduate
and you're never gonna see 99% of them
ever again even with [ __ ] social
media you're never gonna see him again
so you have to listen to your voice and
what the [ __ ] you want to do in life and
you follow that okay and know that when
you set off to make a dream happen that
when you tell people that that's what
you're doing the bigger the dream the
more negative feedback you're gonna get
and you have to understand as Tom Papa
told me that whenever he made a big
decision in life he realized that you
know so much of people's reactions to
what he was doing had nothing to do with
him it was them working out their own
[ __ ] alright and then just be be a
good [ __ ] don't [ __ ] people over try not
to hurt anybody you're a human being
you'll make mistakes
you will just try to own up to them and
try not to repeat your mistakes and
other than that you know be forgiving
yourself and try not to be a [ __ ] there
you go alright notice none of that
involved your grades or having two years
of a [ __ ] language and all that other
horseshit they try to get you to [ __ ]
buy into all right overrated underrated
underrated buying ladies potted plants
all right everyone buys chicks flowers
but what the hell are they gonna do with
the bouquet of flowers that were just
recently murdered by her a plant in a
pot especially a cactus product cacti
will never die
they have spikes all over them and it's
way better than getting a girl a rose
but for whatever reason they they
respond more to the rose than the potted
cacti but I guess you given the body
potted cacti this represents my love
which like the potted cacti will never
die I like where you're going with this
this is also a nice test to to see how
[ __ ] much your wife or girlfriend
watches the Kardashians because if you
don't get them a rose and you get them a
potted cacti and that's maybe a good
lock the door test I kind of liked it I
gotta be honest with you all right
that's it everybody that's all I got for
you that's it yeah I'm hanging in there
I'll [ __ ] your hanging in and in there
I'll check in on ya on Thursday
let me know what music you guys are
listening to God knows I got the [ __ ]
time over here
alright I'll talk to you guys later
alright hang in there stay positive and
it's okay if somebody has a different
opinion than you do we're all [ __ ]
fellow Americans and in a bigger picture
we're all human beings alright so no
matter what the [ __ ] leader tells you
red tie or blue tie if it doesn't make
sense if it seems divisive don't listen
to that [ __ ] alright I like the red
states I like the blue states I like
Canada I like Mexico I like people all
right and all it takes is a couple of
[ __ ] to ruin the whole [ __ ] thing
and once you see that everybody can hang
out and have a good time all right go
[ __ ] yourselves I'll see you soon